What is important in our work is the fact that we can do everything with Mathematica.
Originally, I am an engineer,
and I started in continuum mechanics, including the mechanics of structural materials.
So, what interested me in Mathematica at the time was the ability to do formal calculations
and interacting with numerical calculation.
I teach in a school of architecture, School of Architecture Paris-Malaquais and... Paris Tech, which is an engineering school.
In both schools, I teach... the design of structures and the use of materials in structures.
Currently I am working with 10 doctoral students.
In the laboratory, I have another architectural structure that is the School of Paris-Malaquais,
and the doctoral students, they all work with Mathematica,
because it actually allows us to have this important interaction in today's architecture
between the image, logic, and mathematics.
That's why I said there is a change in the way I used Mathematica.
At the beginning it was mostly for formal calculations and its impact on numerical calculations.
Today we do more numerical calculations than formal calculations.
Mathematica allows the interaction between geometry and the opportunity to interact with architects
and interface to other programs for exporting to other useful formats.
First, there is the scientific aspect.
Mathematica allows me, and the doctoral students I work with,
to have a continuity of problem as it is understood from formal and fundamental viewpoints for programming and exporting results.
There is a great continuity, which means, the alternative would be to use many different tools,
or perhaps tools that are looking to be as wide but less complete.
It allows us at the same time, a magnitude of the fact that we can start from a fundamental process to applications
without changing the software in a manner that we will never have to resort to other questions.
A second factor for me, as a teacher, it is in pedagogy.
I use Mathematica in two different ways in teaching. To show something correct, well designed, well calculated
to students in lecture room without interaction.
And the other is to develop first-year and second-year students in the field,
to develop tools and procedures that allow them to understand a little bit the foundation of the science,
and it is a really important thing in architecture schools.
The third important element has to do precisely with communication.
We are working on an interface that connects two worlds: architecture and engineering.
And these two worlds have their own uses, their own ways of saying things,
which sometimes can create some communication problems.
However, the images are often used as a bridge so that everyone can talk about and understand the same thing.
The third thing Mathematica allows us to is after we maintained all our rigor and love for math and logic,
we can arrive at an exportable final result in another culture without difficulty.